everybody welcome to my brand new he has  a marginal I'm really excited to be here  as you can see we don't have a very hard  to budget here so if you'd like to  donate to my paypal there will be a link  in the description okay let's get  started huh today's gonna be really fun  and also just like to say that we are  not sponsored by I choose but if I  choose would like to sponsor us I would  definitely take the money would you like  some I choose I have so many here do you  like red or green or purple that's for  you  well guys that's the end of our episode  I'll be revealing much more relaxed I  sure AM  I hope you have a great day and thanks  for watching don't forget to subscribe  you